which is basically first blockchain
platform in syncopal to issue the
education certificate on blockchain
and I've been in software development
swirling
and also building and the rest stops
using
so today again guys we will go through
the basics of web components and then we
will talk about the elements of web
components and we will be like to do
demo using web components
can listen
[Music]
and after that we will build check
application using the element which is
one of three web component framework and
then we will talk about how we can
integrate web components with the
existing project which you just type I
kill I really like see I can with all
those Fugees exciting yeah Facebook okay
so web components is the set of
standards to like modulars useable an
encapsulated HTML elements basically in
today's world if you are working on the
front and side so before proceeding I
just want to ask one thing
how many of you have worked on web
components like raise your hand ever
heard of web components okay how many of
you are working on the front-end
framework like any framework heard of
components okay so basically in today
put the edge work everything is on the
components
everything is component which can be
reused encapsulated and can't be
modernized for your application so every
Apple every framework react.js angular
by google or anything they have all
introduced components but the only
problem is like technology is evolving
really fast so if any of you have worked
on angular 1 and when X which 2 and we
were to it was the drastic change the
whole application were broken and there
was aching from the scratch again so you
cannot depend on the third-party library
framework always for that web components
has been there for since quite a long
time but since quite furiously support
on the browser form for web components
has been drastically moved and now most
of the latest browser supports the web
components so why they are huge
that framework agnostic they don't
depend on any framework and there are
the Kenyan vanilla JavaScript you don't
need any kind of secondary language for
that so via web components
it's basically extremal is not romantic
enough to understand there is no
standard templating system there is no
native encapsulation in browser
basically you can not encapsulate all
the styles or your markup so that it
don't get oversights by the global or
parent CSS there is no way to reuse the
existing HTML and everything is
component as we talk so what are the
goals of web components it's basically
to the use of a existing code to
encapsulate the styling and markups it
provides the separation of concerns it
provides the better composition and for
theming purpose it's really best when
you want to provide this theme to your
application and it's pretty much
expressive because you define your
elements by yourself and it's semantics
this is the browser support basically if
you see most of the latest browser
supports web components except for the
Internet Explorer which is a skill are
developing the support for especially
custom elements and shadow Dom and apart
from that chrome opera and Safari
pretty much support web components so
these are the four parts of a standard
web components basically templates
imports I go Dom and custom M elements
templates are nothing but we will java
HTML which you can define and we use in
other application imports it basically
introduced in es6 if you know they are
basically to import the HTML file in
your application it gives you
flexibility so that you can write or web
components and dot HTML file and you
in another HTML shadow Dom it's
basically to encapsulate two markups all
CSS and custom elements which basically
gives you the flexibility to define your
own elements so let's talk about every
standard of web components so custom
elements it basically gives you the
flexibility to alter your own component
you can name your own component my cool
component or whatever you want and you
can define your component and tell the
parcel how you want to pass it in your
application what are the events you want
to handle on that event what all the
markups you want to handle on that
particular element so how elements of
that particular class will react to some
changes you can pass the props you can
pass the exhibits you can define
properties on that particular elements
and customer events always define in a
prefix - name so you will always have a
hyphen between the custom elements so
that it doesn't get messed up within
native HTML elements next one is shadow
Dom which is basically to encapsulate
your styling and markups so whenever you
define a shadow Dom it's basically a
catcher gone subtree to your dome root
and that dome subtree is encapsulated
and the junk I cover they didn't buy
your global scope CSS all markups it's
really great for modularity so that you
can just use that modular components
anywhere in your application is module
is nothing but it's for reuse and
inclusion of the J's documents impact
it's also you can use it for HTML and
CSS to import in your other application
HTML templates
it's basically defined using template
tags and it's good because this extremal
template code reject the judgment by
itself until you activate this code so
any kind of image any kind of a script
written inside that HTML tag won't get
loaded until you will activate this
particular code these are the life cycle
provided with the custom elements it's
basically a constructor is by default
with any class you can define connected
callback is every time you lower
components get created and it gets
attached to the Dom tree similarly
disconnected to clear your memory and
can usually attach all the events
attribute change callback it's similarly
whenever you pass a property or
attribute to components this particular
lifecycle method will get called and
adopted callback is nothing when you
reuse your custom elements from vendôme
elements to another dome elements so
here is the sorts definitions when you
can use the Constructors basically
whenever your elemental gets created
your constructor gets executed and it's
good for setting up the initial State
event listeners binding the event
listeners and creating this atom
connected callback age venule custom
elements inserted into the dome and it's
basically good for fetching data making
ejects calls and setting the default
attributes in your application in this
connected callback similarly to detach
your event listener or cancel time
interval for your memory of your
application
attribute change callback is called like
any time element observed like stable
changes so there's one this static
method which is provided in the custom
elements observed attribute where you
can define your variables or observables
which is going to change in the future
and these attributes can file this
executes change callback a life cycle
method every time so it has three
parameters named old value and new value
name it basically the name of your
attribute which you have defined all
values the previous value and name new
values the change value of that
particular elements adopt a call back as
I told you like whenever you change your
dome or move your dome to a new
documents it get caught called it's
basically useful manually using iframe
in your application and there's one more
method of a change available which is
custom elements not defined which is
used to register other elements into the
JavaScript and it uses custom elements
registry and it defined using window dot
customer you might store define you will
give the name of to your element and
provide the class you have created for
that particular element so this is the
application we are going to base now so
before that I'm going to start with one
basic example which is hello world and
for that I think everyone is connected
with the Wi-Fi right
so one thing everyone can do can
download HTTP server
everyone has npm with them like install
on their computer yeah just install this
HTTP server which will help us to come
basically I'll sign our server and we
will use this to sign our website
sorry guys
a place to sit
[Music]
we
Thank You Sunday
okay so for the new people who had just
arrived we have just gone through the
basics of web component six definition
and what are the parts we are going to
use to create our web component so we
are going to start with the demo of
hello world which is the basic demo and
we will modify that demo to create a
to-do app later on so I hope everyone
has installed the HTTP server which I am
going to use to learn my server
I think everyone has installed the HTTP
servers right let's just start with
adding one index dot HTML file and we
will like the body tag in it and if you
want you can add the tag tag with it
also
okay
with day we are going to include our
javascript file which we are going to
create so i'm going to give a script
tiger source that i'm going to create
one file
hello world gorgeous which will be
included here and this a lowboy file we
define a web component which it has a
world which later on i am going to use
it
okay
this is the very basic HTML file in
which I have a body tag and I am loading
one script and I'm defining one web
component let's open a new tab and write
JavaScript files so we are going to use
the self invoking function basically we
don't want to expose our context to our
outside so I'm going to do the self
invoking function inside which I am
going to define a function basically
this is the self invoking function in
our hello world dot j us and in with
this I am going to define a class
HelloWorld and so every web component
every custom elements will define it
extends one class which is HTML elements
I am going to inherit that class
okay so let me just save this file so
that it will I will give it a name index
dot HTML and I will save this file as
HelloWorld gorgeous okay
so first of all we have defined the
class and we have extended the HTML
element HTML elements gives us the
flexibility to attach all the native
HTML elements properties to our custom
defined elements so now we are going to
use the custom elements not defined
property to define our element so we
will like and we will give it a name
hello world and we will type the class
here
so this line tells JavaScript okay this
is the hello Boyle tag which has been
defined by the user and it can be used
as a world in my index dot HTML where I
have loaded this everyone's okay now I'm
going to define the constructor and I'm
going to call the super super is
basically to inherit the props from your
parent class which is in our case HTML
element so before that I'm going to need
my template also so I'm going to define
a constant template and I'm going to
create my temperature
okay
now I'll say I'll just put the innerhtml
to some day
I know
and
currently I am just going to protect
eyes oh boy
yeah
and now
I'm going to attach this shadow with the
mode open I will explain this mode later
like why I have used this mode and I
will tell you I like
good
by that
and I'm going to obtain this as a child
my can take and order
Oh
I turn and God
okay so what I am doing here I am in
this current context I am attaching this
I go DOM and in the shadow root I am
appending my template content you and
cloning its content - it's a code so now
let's try to execute this code
you can just run your server using a
10px HTTP - server
and just copy-paste
no realistic
hmm
nope
hmm
another experiment
okay
yeah so okay so we have overhead over
here let's try to modify this hello
world code and I'm going to put dynamic
content here with the hello
so much awesome thing and we will pass
this name as a property to our web
component
so
so as we said before of what all these
selectors all the template exciting will
be here in connected callback so we are
going to define another cycle method
connected callback
and I'm going to say this document is
equal to
[Music]
in this got side door query selector and
I'm going to select the strong here
anger
I'm going to use the attribute change
callback a lifecycle method also which
is going to update our another schema
love this strong
it's basically takes three parameters
your name rose oil value and the new
value
so I'm just going to do this dot and ice
cause element and got tax content is go
to new value
so when we define a variable properties
or attribute on a custom elements we
learned before that we have to define a
static method which is observed
attribute inside which we are going to
define the attribute so we are going to
define this method here expected get
observed attribute which basically
returns the array of all the observed
value we are going to give this
attribute or name or name and even you
can check it
you can just call it curve
and we are going to pass this name as a
property here
okay
so
everyone is following here yeah this
basically defines in your custom
elements what are the variables are
observable in your custom elements so
which are the observable variables you
are going to define in this area so any
other property if you want to pass like
anything name surname or year date of
birth you can define it here and
whenever you will use this attribute and
you define different kind of name here
suppose I am going to say so this
observed value will call this attribute
change callback method one like Lex
- hey
a little
and you might
fun
sweet
[Music]
except a little problem over again the
next morning and look at together
into Chance Qualifier
so the tool
which one
you know exactly the stick
[Music]
thank you lord
okay
I think I could define her
yeah okay
so there was one problem we need to
define the element inside the
constructor where we are using our query
selector and inside the attribute change
callback we are defining the text
content using the new value and if we
use an act you will see like four
different instance of our has a void
component you will have the different
value with it
and you will see the source code for
this you can see the shadows vote in
your inspect element and you can see it
opens again after this I do shadowed
this open basically gives you the
flexibility to access the strength of
your custom said all outside the dome so
after this set if you want to suppress
your differential hello alga element
support document dot query selector has
no void and you want to perform any
operation with the open method you can
do that as soon as you will make it
close you won't be able to access the
reference to the hello world of Sega
wrote outside this particular context
so
these are this is the dynamic method
next method we are going to try using
slots so everyone is following okay so
next method we are going to try using
slots slots has nothing but placeholders
in your template which gives you the
flexibility to dynamically change the
content of your template so instead of
using the strong I am going to use this
slot and I will give slug like this name
property with which you can say friends
this lock in your application so it's
basically I am going to say okay my
gamma is the name of this lot
and I'm going to comment this agony
so whenever you use flawed you don't
need to pass this property instead you
define your native HTML elements and it
like give and you give it a slot
property and inside this you will
reference your slot name which is
basically my demo and you will pass it
and I'm going to like something
finger D I'm going to use it here
another group and I'm going to die and
they of course
next time
yeah
yeah
in jeaious instead of a strong selected
I have used this lot and I have given it
a name my demo then I don't need to use
the query selector or anything in my
campaign
so this log will give you the
flexibility to add the dynamic elements
in your custom elements suppose you have
to find some you will attribute and you
want to have the dynamic as I attribute
inside it you can define that using
slots in your application sorry it's
this it's just closure
Indian beauty hold on a little there is
nothing as all the golden age commented
you just directly put this like that
check
the second award is blocked
which one yeah I'm the friend thing the
same slog but the contented changing
between both elements
this is the same element but the inside
content is different there is a s
context the Zestimate
yeah that same so flock is a placeholder
in your components elements basically
which is dynamic it's basically the
children of your elements which is
purely dynamic and variable
so this section which is here I have to
find this slot I have given it a name to
the forensic into my HTML to the
forensic into my any other HTML or
components where I want to use this lot
in my template okay second part
yeah
okay
I have only the first of all you have to
find this door okay let's go
you find the device works
hello we're closing the closing of edges
you can start by return
toldja
I hear you're running this boat actually
the just this is a which you are using
you have to find this launcher on your
element you have to defined it into a
little element this is going to
but although inspector came
you had ingested to define this Lord
here
so you have to find this log here you
need to define this load on your element
[Music]
yeah
my demo this is wrong you cannot
yeah that's why it's not working
the flood should be on your native HTML
elements where you are going to define
all which part you want to make the
variable and say French in your template
basically so this Park is going to be
variable for a placeholder for my custom
elements so I'm going to define this log
here and give it the text so if anyone's
coded not working please make sure that
you have to find the slots on the native
HTML element
everyone is okay okay
okay so pausing to do demo
can you please clone this code on your
local system we are going to use this
project tree which is basically for our
to do demo and the next application
check applications we are going to use
it it has two folders one is completed
code which you can use it for reference
and one is our demo which we are going
to work on
I'm going to paste the
now
[Music]
so everyone has cloned the depo
pleasure
it should be right
the season runs
tiny to check it and this would be
freaking should be to drink with this
somehow
if you not fetch it from
there's that clean
normally doesn't do that actually like
flexibility of web components it just
only changes the tax itself so that it
won't give you the flicker
[Music]
everyone had cloned this repo
Wi-Fi password is here
Wi-Fi Wi-Fi password reject in here
password DJ's corn fascia Wi-Fi La Jolla
J scones so and even eject please copy
and pasted
okay so in your codebase there would be
two folders one is the child demo and
one is the to do embassy we are going to
cover to do MVC right now later on we
will check the check demo which is
basically using the lake element and
fall for your friends there is completed
code is also they can in the demo
complete which you can check out later
on if you need the difference
so for to do MVC we have defined three
components for our application one is
the parent component which is to go demo
and then to do list and to-do item to do
this case the diaper component which is
going to triangle do all the equal to
items inside you so
let's start with the goo-goo demo of a
change our first component which we are
going to hide
similarly like hello world we have to
find the template see I created a
template and put one in the HTML here in
the inner HTML I have defined three
sections basically head of section and
footer Peggle is nothing but your input
box where we are going to type the to do
demo section is the Lisp which will show
you the to do list and for tell it show
you the count of decoders which are
active right now so this is our template
which is going to render in our
application legs we have defined this to
do demo class and we are going to define
this element first so let's use bring
those odd custom elements not defined
and I will give it a name to go demo and
I will pass the class here
okay
now let's go to our constructor itself
we need to bind this to method first so
we are going to bind the method this dot
new to Dukey up
and we are going to bind another night
Rodolfo
now in our connected callback we are
going to append the host so before that
we also need to define the we have also
defined the disconnected callback which
is basically just to remove the event
listeners or the necessary cleanup on
our code so we are just going to use
this dot inner HTML and we are going to
assign it append determined
Oh God a pencil
we are just going to open the content of
the camp liquor
next we are going to bind some event
listeners which we are going to use I'm
going to the friends them from the
complete demo again but actually
[ __ ]
[Music]
[Music]
so we are going to use key up and to do
this change event listeners so key up is
basically nothing when we press the
Intel to open input box we are going to
egg the egg back to do into our demo and
to do this changes nothing but to
refresh the count in our application
we are going to remove this is never in
our disconnected call back
so I had just copy pasted this
additional cleanup from the completed
file so I have added to listeners key
append to do this change and remove
deliciousness in our disconnected
callback to clean up it apart from that
I am going to need few query selector to
put the operations to put the event on
my to do list so these are the query
selectors which is basically I am going
to use
and so our to do next query selector is
nothing but the placeholder which is
going to show the list of all the to do
is in the weather application and you to
do class I have selected to check the I
catch the event to our input box in our
to do demo then another main class which
is basically nothing but this X in class
the list of to do is we are going to
perform some operations there like delay
to move all the idea and the last word
not least to do count which is basically
we are going to show the count of our
todos in our application
good
let's try to learn this code for now and
see the UI like how it looks
okay so if we will then this code they
say however you I will look we have
worked the CSS and everything all they
did there in a HTML file kind of
currently I will do anything I will do
nothing for me
so what we have done till now till now
we have defined that to do their more
custom elements and inside the element
we have defined our templates for to do
demo which is basically the input box
and the list we are going to solve and
the focus action inside that template we
have also introduced one another custom
elements like to-do list where we are
going to wrangle all our tools inside
our connected callback we have used all
the query selector for to perform the
different operations and we have
attached all the events key append to do
change and then we did the cleanup in
our disconnected callback and grease
methods I'm going to explain it later on
let's go to our to-do list file
so to-do list inside to-do list if you
will see we have created the template
elements and give it a slot so slot is
nothing but the variable content inside
your template so here in this section we
are going to define some content we are
going to add some content which it will
be all particular to those contents or
text which are going to we are going to
show there so as we saw enable hello
world example we are going to append
complex to a beside those would so
before that we are going to attach this
I do the de mode open
and we are going to cloneable template
[Music]
okay everyone is following
sorry before that we also need to define
our components actually
in our kinetic callback we are going to
add one listener to listen for the slot
change every time the content of this
Lord to fill change
and in our disconnected callback will
similarly remove the listener
so every time I will slow content will
change what we will do we will remove
all these nodes which are unknown to G
to do this elements so for that we are
going to use the node type element which
is nothing but we are going to look
through all the child nodes and we are
going to check for the node type if node
type is one which is basically tells
it's a native HTML element and we are
going to check it check tag name if it's
not a to-do item we are going to remove
it from our list and then we are going
to dispatch the event basically
[Music]
so I'm going to dispatch this custom
event to do this change and with that I
am going to deliver the to-do item
element counts which are basically that
all the counts which I have assigned to
my slot here so this can be accessible
through assign nodes to that particular
slot
and dislike is nothing but the query
selector of this vlog which we have
initialized in the world constructor
let's see what it will change
cool
it's a No I have created return object
okay
these seeds
he could release thinkable is designed
to do is change
go to itemize my count
the cutest check it from the store just
dispersing the scene
are they
you want to be here
okay so this to-do list is going give
going to give us the functionality to
listen for that to do change event and
update the number of tools we have at it
so now we need to add the list of todos
which we are going to sew down here for
that we are going to work on to go item
so by default whenever you define a
template and say those would its host
element has this tiling markup of inline
so by default it doesn't take the high
convict so it's better for you to define
some height and width on your host so
you can either change the styling of
your host or put some and if you don't
need the height and width on your host
you can just use the existing styling so
here I'm going to give it some styling
from my go to item
so for my goal type make it this little
block and I did some borders and so on
sighs you know we we like the all these
guiding letters on it see this part
again we are going to similarly define
the elements first
and similarly we are going to attach
this I do and clone the Templar conclude
this ago
Dark Lord
apart from that I have added few methods
which are basically check box or
different operation on our to do which
we are going to see later and similarly
I have selected few elements from my
to-do list templates so this is my
templates project to do you will see
there is an input box label to assign
the label for my to-do destroy button
which is basically to remove the to do
and there would be an ident button to
perform the addition on my Kudo
inside connected callback I have just
added all these listeners on different
for the particular to do what I am going
to do I am going to add the addicted to
D change the attached remove the to do
and update the to do so I have added
different kinds of operations click
events and double-click and block events
and in the disconnected callback I just
remove all the listeners attached and
electable change callback I am going to
just check for the switch case which
will check for if it's a label all
completed and I'm going to assign the
value to it so it's nothing but 2
in this cold
so what I'm going to do if my attribute
name is Ray well I'm just going to make
it text content to the new value and my
activity is completed I'm going to mark
its checkbox as a child with this dot
completed property one thing you can
also notice we are going to define these
two properties as our observable also so
I am going to define these here label
and computed
mmm
pick
let's try to sign it
second great recycling it was for the
ones
hmm
the satellite also
sorry
okay
once we define I have put some code in
hay gate current cycle code inside it
which is basically used to set or gate
or observable properties in your custom
elements so I've used two methods said
completed and site level and similarly
guy completed and gate level which is
basically to say our observable
attribute
and
these are the different methods which we
are going to use to make our to-do list
to perform different operations
basically we are going to blur the text
as soon as you click on the check box
and you can click a double click on the
to-do list to educate
and there should be removed by time
so what's a completely
okay so we are missing some CSS here we
are going to I am going to copy pasted
it from the original elements
yeah so this is all this is our to-do
list demo using vanilla JavaScript next
we are going to look into lake element
which marking is going to explain but
before that we are going to take a break
for ten minutes
for the second part of our vulture
so yeah we just witness how we can able
to build web components using just
vanilla jazz without using any library
or using any framework but for this
second part of the workshop we will be
using lip element so there are already
libraries and frameworks that helps us
to build web components so libraries
such as hybrid polymers Kate Jas little
element slim Jas this already libraries
that we can use for us to be able to
build web components a bit faster and
easier so for the frameworks we also
have this custom elements everywhere
calm we're in it lists all the it shows
us how compatible the framework is when
it comes to the web components so we can
try to take a quick look so for for this
one we can see that angular has a good
rating angularjs hyper HTML lip element
polymer thing crack is somehow a bit low
when it comes to web component support
but hopefully in the future they will
cover most of the features and yet
circle as blue multi and view so
yeah also a apart from that I guess
frameworks like angular and view also
had their own tools for instance for
angular they have this angular element
for view they have this view web web
component wrapper Internet I'm not
mistaken and also a stencil also is a
framework that helped us to build web
components so yeah we're going to use
lip but what is lead element so little
Ahmet is basically just a base class for
creating fast lightweight web components
that work in any webpage without any
framework it is lit HTML properties are
observed by default elements update as
synchronously when their property change
so we can think of somehow lip element
like an enhancement or an improved
version of the HTML element
so lip hTML is the templating library
that we're going to use later on
so basically lit HTML allows us to
define or write our HTML templates using
just plain JavaScript with the use of
template literals so if you notice on my
right side you'll see this is how pre-op
video right rear Enders or reruns every
time they have an update while on the
left side this is how lit HTML does this
rendering so if if we take a look at the
h1 element what happens is the whole
node is actually being rendered while
Inlet HTML only the dynamic tags which
are the with those numbers represents
art the only ones to is changing so
thank you for code words for the image
and yeah so basically somehow lip hTML
is a bit or a slightly faster compared
to video it's like 30 to 40 percent
faster depending on your browser and
then the I think the only slight problem
that we have for the LM HTML is actually
during its first render it's somehow a
bit slow but yeah I think in the future
they will improve that because actually
lip HTML it's not using any video
overhead or it's not using any different
algorithm it's purely using web
standards so it's leveraging the web
standards like it uses the built-in
parser
HTML parser of the browser it is a swig
map
type template literal so for this slide
I want you to somehow focus a bit on the
template binding bindings because this
is what we're going to use mostly later
on when we're building our chat
component so - do you attribute binding
we just simply do let's say class
attribute then the data CSS class
nothing that's special but when it comes
to boolean attribute we need to use
question mark for property binding we
need to use the period and for event
binding we need to use the add sign so
as I mentioned earlier let element is
like an extension of HTML element so all
the life cycle that was mentioned by
Suman earlier can still be used when
building lead element but apart from
that little element added some couple of
life cycle but I won't be able to
discuss discuss each one by one because
we won't be able to tackle everything
for this workshop as we don't have that
much of a time but just too quick to
give you a quick overview the lead
element update cycle starts when we set
a property so then afterwards lead
element will request an update if there
is a change in the property so by
default it tracks whether the old value
is equal or not equal to the new value
so after that it will do the D perform
date then she'll update this should
update is somehow similar to I guess the
react lifecycle component should update
we're in
by default this one returns true but if
you want to somehow prevent the
component from rendering you can return
false on this part for the update no
need to override no need to implement
it's just we just lit element has this
life cycle after in between should
update and render were in in this update
the reflection or properties to
attributes is happening and then we have
this render this one we will use this
one most of the time this is where we
define our HTML template the first
updated it's like this one is once the
template has been created it will call
it will be called but this one only
happened one so any one time work that
you need can be implemented here and
then the updated this is this happens
once the the updated or the element has
been rendered and finally the apt a
complete actually this update complete
is not a method it's more on a property
that resolves in to a promise but this
one we also won't be covering for this
workshop so in let element we have we we
declare properties somehow like this we
need to to type in static properties
then return at just an object with the
property name then the property options
so for the property of shots mostly will
will be using the type reflect and no
access are so for the type these are the
types the or D the default types that we
have for lead element is
string object are a boolean and number
so for the attribute this is we're not
also going to tackle that but if you see
if by default if we do reflect if we
mentioned that reflux is true then if we
change the property to value to
something it will get reflected to an
attribute also called as property T so
if we specify an attribute is like just
whenever prop one has changed the value
will be set to D or will be reflected to
the mine - attribute attr so I guess
that's this are the property options
that available for little hello so what
we're going to do for today is we're
going to build just a simple chat
component so it has four components so
the first one is the demo this is the
main component or the entry point
component so this in this one we will
just need to identify whether we should
show chat lobby where you can see once
were so at first we will display the
chat lobby then afterwards once we enter
the user name we now see the chat room
with the chat messages so I think we can
now start
so I hope that a while ago that you have
already downloaded the repos that was
mentioned by assume it so if you can go
to the inside
demo chat folder you'll find the client
folder
so
so for for this one we have we have five
folders one is angular yeah one is for
angular one is for react one is for view
server and lion so for the integration
it will be covered by submit afterwards
so basically in these folders this
angular react and view folder we will
see how we we can integrate ditch a
component that we built into these
frameworks so for now the client
component that we are going to build is
located in the client folder I also have
server folder it's just a plain
WebSocket server if you want to try or
run but it's this server is actually not
necessary if you you can skip it for now
we but we will be able just we will see
just a single error when we're building
it's like WS our WebSocket connectivity
error or something like that but it's
okay because it will not crash our
application so running server is like an
optional thing
so before we begin first as we look into
the package that today's I'm so what I
have here is just I'm using of course
the little man and I'm also using the
old WC dev server but you can also use
polymer CLI if you want to run a server
or any server but for this workshop I
prefer to use Adobe's see if that server
and we just have roll up for bundling
maybe afterwards afterwards we will be
we will use this paneling just to
somehow integrate the chat component
into react or view and yeah I only have
start and build script so first what we
need to do is I guess is we need to npm
install
yeah
so now let's create a source folder
it's our seed and in here we'll create
the first grade the chat message by the
way for for this one we'll just use
thank JavaScript but you can also use
typescript if you want but yeah for this
workshop that's just really JavaScript
so first thing to do is to import the
lit element and the HTML and the CSS
helpers
so yeah now let's start creating our
glass so let's name this one as a chat
message which extends instead of HTML we
use lead element so somehow this is look
familiar because somehow this is similar
to what we did earlier when we're
building what components using vanilla
dress also we need to define let's call
it chat - message and each child message
so for lip element that they basic or
requirements that we need is first this
we need to define our template second is
also we need to provide our Styles and
yeah we need to render it so let's start
first by creating a render function so
we need to read this is where we will
write our HTML template
so just to check that this is somehow
working we can just write chat message
and then go into the index.html then for
this one we'll use es6 module so the
type should be module ten source let's
point it to the chat message
and now we use be chat message
so to run this one you should just
should be able to run it this NPM start
and
yeah should be good to go
yeah so yeah we were able to create our
first component but of course this is
not final yet but we can somehow see
that we already have our chat message
working so what to do next the next
thing to do is we should define our own
styles
and just simply so for this one you need
to use the CSS helper it's similar on
what we did for the render and then we
put in our style so for now let's just
see whether we can add background and
let's just say that this one display
that
yeah so we were able to apply our style
so as actually we can add our Styles
here as well we can add this style or
external style sheet we can add it here
however as per lead element it is highly
recommended to use the static get Styles
instead because somehow what lead
element does is it tries to use the
constructible style sheets objects so if
the browser supports the constructible
size its object somehow what's that the
constructible style sheet object does is
it allows us to parse and reuse these
style sheets only once so for maximum
efficiency they're using constructible
style sheets as well if only if the VARs
are supported so
I think one more thing that we need to
do of course later on we're going to
change the styles and the template so we
can also define the properties
so for this we need to return an object
then let's say I think for the hello
world sample if I'm not mistaken we is
named as the D property so we can also
do it that
then for the type it's just string
then with a lead element to reflect
whenever the property changes us we tell
little element to reflect the value to
the attribute so this seed that happens
let's use
the property that we define under
properties inside D render
by the way if we need to somehow
initialize or have a default value for
our for our properties we should do it
in the constructor so let's say the
default value for name is equals to
hello
so yeah we see sorry it's not that clear
maybe we can change the color to white
yeah so now we have the name property
the name property developed value is
hello so there's two things that we can
check here is first is since we
mentioned that whenever our property
changes us it should reflect to this
attribute so
yeah we can try that here let's say we
change the name to well we see that this
changes as well as the attribute here
the attribute name here but what if we
change this or we remove this one what
will happen so what will happen is
whenever we change the name property
yeah it will not just reflect so if we
want for a property to get reflected to
the HTML element we just say reflect to
so I guess that's the I mean basic to
get us started for building this shat
message so starting now
I might need a bit of a copy/paste skill
so let's go on to
the chat message so for this one I'll be
copying this one first
and then for the properties we're going
to have two properties one is from and
the other one is outgoing so what this
is is from Isla it's more on the name of
the server so that we will be able to
see in the chat message where the
message came from who who's the sender
of the message and outgoing is just a
flag for us to identify whether it
should be a line ripe or aligned left
so I also need to copy all the styles
yeah
yeah
so I think we now have or we have now
completed the chat message but for just
to have a quick idea of what is
happening on this render portion so
first is when I'm ready the dis or the
from property changeless we will get the
value and if be from as null or
undefined or it's not set so by default
we will have the anonymous as a value
then the initial is just like the first
we will get the first letter of the name
then for the HTML template first is just
the badge wherein we just pass in or
bind the initial also we did the same
for the name and we're also using slots
because for slots we want the content or
the yeah the content of the template of
our HTML tag to be projected on this
person so if we now try to modify this
shut message and we add let's say Martin
then say hello
they ask on
yeah so now we have this element so we
can also see how it looks when
it is an outgoing oops sorry
so basically if it's outgoing the
direction will be on the right side
portion but if it's not you should see
it on the left side so if we since we do
reflect so we should see outgoing here
so I guess since now we have the chat
message we can now proceed on creating
our chat room so we first create a file
new file so since we already done the
basic stuff so as much as possible I
want you to create this chat room maybe
just the skeleton or in you add the
re-import delete element then you write
in the class with a chatroom message
that extends that element then add the
static add properties static add styles
and the render also don't forget to
define your element TV chat - true
so yeah so I hope that you able to come
up with this structure
so first what I'm going to do is first
as we need to have new properties
username and the message list
so we can type in
string and message list which is an
array
so for this one I'll just copy the
styles
[Music]
and I'll just quickly copy
yonder
so if one thing that we use in these
styles is if you're familiar with a CSS
variables D native CSS variables or the
psy.d custom CSS properties we're
currently using that here because later
on when we try to integrate this one in
react or in view we will be able to
somehow change the look and feel of our
chat component
so for for this one it's I think it will
be somehow I know I think every I assume
that everyone have this H I mean that is
familiar with type template letters or
template literals so for this one we can
do the look here but we need to return
the HTML element if not we won't be able
to see this one rendered if we're not
using the HTML element for displaying
the element so if one thing that we need
to DC is this one so this we use the
boolean attribute binding so if in case
you're wondering why we need to use the
boolean attribute binding for this one
if we change this one to this we might
get some error earlier big in the future
because what will happen by default
is if this message outgoing is not false
or undefined the outgoing value will be
undefined string since which is not what
we supposed to do that's why we're using
the boolean because if we use the
boolean what happens is the value that
this outgoing property will receive is
just bully it's pure just through or
false now not string boolean
so I'll also be copying the rest of the
code yes
so
what what we're doing here is first we
define our own custom setter and getter
if if you still remember earlier in the
slide I'm I have mentioned the no access
er so by default lit element provides
the provides us the access or so they do
implement the setter and getter by
default but for this case we did our own
accessors so we added our own setter and
getter so for this one we actually don't
need these requests update because the
user n-- word we're not using the user
name for the rendering so we don't want
the lead element to re-render whenever
the user name property change so one of
the things that we need to take notice
if we add our own custom access or we
need to trigger the request update
manually and pass in the name like what
we're doing here earlier you need to
pass an name for this case username and
the old value for D lip HTML to do its
rendering again we need to trigger this
Wed manually when writing our own custom
accessories but for this case as I
mentioned we don't need this as we don't
need lead element to re-render whenever
the user name changes what this does is
just whenever we provide him the user
name it will try to connect us WebSocket
server
and for the one of the lifecycle hooks
that was mentioned earlier is the first
updated so in here we can have our
reference to the input in this case and
also you can also put your let's say if
you're going to do focus on the input
after the element has been created for
the first time you can do that on this
cycle life cycle
so I think that's it for the chat room
so if we go on to the index that HTML
and if we replace this the chat room
I hope we should be able to see
yeah we're inside the chat room
so one thing I want you to take note of
is if you see whenever we are then oh I
have an error
oh we for need also to import the chat
room
add the chat message rather because we
remove the chat message from this one
from index and since we need the chat
message inside the chat room we need to
import the chat message so now we should
be there so yeah so yeah we just have
this
undefined error because we didn't
provide a username
I think what we can do is instead of
yeah we need to prevent it
yeah so yeah now we have this name and
the message and the initial so if you
notice we have this error but we can
ignore this one as I mentioned earlier
but for this one I want you to take note
of this because what we did is whenever
we add a message to the message list
it's like we're getting all the message
and concatenating it with the new
message this is because by default if we
do mutation change on our array or
object lead element will not be able to
know if something has changed on that
object or on this array so one thing we
can do is we can actually try to use
push we can push the new message object
instead but for
for the lip element to be rendered we
need to mention the request update
manually but first I just comment this
one first so that we can see that our
app is not working I mean we were adding
but it's not rear-ending because as I
mentioned if we do mutate the object or
D RA by default lit will not be able to
identify whether change happened in an
array or object so we need to trigger
request update manually
so now if we type in we see the same
result
so we can keep that get this one Jan
this and now I guess we can start
creating D chat lobby
so let's first create a new file and
call it chat lobby so we're just going
to do the same thing first we need to
import the other man then the HTML and
CSS helpers
then create our class let's name it chat
lobby and extent lip element also we
need to define our element
we call it chat lobby and we pass in the
chat lobby class
next thing to do is to write the static
get properties if we need but for this
case I think we need if I remember it
correctly we also need of course to
provide our styles
and lastly the render so for this one
I'm also going to copy and paste I guess
we don't have that much time yeah so I
need to copy these stars first
or maybe yes copy everything
so what is new here I guess there's
nothing here it's just we're doing the
same we also have provided our exposing
our CSS variables for the chat lobby
and then I think the new thing that
we're doing here is we're dispatching an
event a host of event which we did it
earlier I guess and to-do lists up if
you remember correctly we also dispatch
our own custom event so we just we also
added that here so this is for us to
identify whether the user have entered
his name or not or he if he already
wants to enter the room or not
so we dispatch an event once the room
the the user clicks on the join room so
for this one we we all did as well as we
bind the event as I mentioned earlier
one binding event we need to use the @
at-sign
and then yet there's
yeah I guess we also did the event
binding earlier so we can or should we
should now try the event [ __ ] at lobby
rather
for the chutney we don't have any
properties required so you should notice
we don't have these static yet
properties
yeah and by default if you remember
earlier were manually cleaning up all
the events that we have added for thee
to do this up but in this case let HTML
handles that one for us so we don't need
to worry about cleaning up the events
that we have here but if of course if we
do R or if we add manually our own
listener and this one then we should
remove that manually but by default if
we use the lead HTML event binding
cleaning up the events is being taken
care of us by little HTML so we now have
we now added the chat lobby in the index
so yeah we're now able to see that this
is the chat lobby so I guess finally we
need
to create last component with which is
shot demo so I'll just copy everything
so for this one there's only a few lines
on the chat demo because what this does
is it actually just toggles the chat
lobby and chat room but for for this one
let's try it first
for D chat demo if you notice we also
imported via chat lobby and chat room so
we only have two properties disjoint and
the username so joint is just an
indicator whether the user joined the
room or not and username so for for this
one if we can now see if we type in our
name and join the room we were able to
yes successfully hide the lobby and show
the chat room instead so another thing
that we can do here is instead of doing
this hidden boolean attribute binding we
can also have conditionals inside so
let's try that
so what we do instead of hidden we
remove this hidden or the
yeah we can
yeah we're so we remove the boolean
attribute binding so we can then check
whether it's not if it if the user is
not yet joined then we shall the chat
lobby otherwise we shall the chat room
so for this one you also need to return
a template
result
so yeah so we were just doing some
ternary here so we're checking if the
user has joined or not if the user is
not yet entered the room so we will
display the chat lobby otherwise we'll
show chat room yeah
yes
sorry
yeah sorry
if this joint at River this HTML
sorry I don't you disjoint conditional
copy to the random methods oh oh
okay we can try it happen try that
actually
mostly I but I think it will still work
so
it's like this one
yeah both will work I believe so that's
right
yeah this fact
yeah it's still the same but just to
make sure that we have sorry
just to make sure that this has changed
let's try to add fake attribute or say
class
a glass
so if we
and third yeah so any approach this will
work but I think yeah this one is a bit
cleaner
so I guess that's it for the shot demo
for the integration of the shot demo it
will be done by some in web components
to basically see how we can integrate
them with our existing projects which we
have all the idea that Union side FICO
framework so do you guys need a break
before like okay so we can have a
10-minute break and then we can see how
we can integrate it in our existing
projects
with any third-party library framework
so I'm going to show you how we can
integrate it with react and there are
similar steps which we can follow with
mostly angular of UGS or any other
third-party library so there is polyfill
you will need to install if you want to
application to supports for all the
browsers especially for the Internet
explosion and there is one polyfill
available web component J's which you
can always install to support it apart
from like the Bengal copy which is
available for the edgiest to copy all
the Bengal files into your own
repository so in your packet go Jason
you can write a post install the script
which is basically will whenever you do
npm install this PostScript post install
will get executed and it will execute a
bengal copy script which basically
wander takes the custom elements es5 by
depth earth and polyfill which is web
components from Wendell dodges and copy
it into your public folder so that later
on we can utilize this in our index dot
HTML and in your index dot HTML you need
to add these three files in a three
lines basically you are including the
same computed file in your index dot
HTML that's it
that's how you can support it in your
react or any existing application where
you want to integrate the web components
so if you'll see we have like one of the
we have put all the code for the angular
react and view into this project tree if
you want to look at it look at them
apart from that if you will see here in
the code base
Oh
so in my packing on Jason I have ended I
did my vendor copy script which will do
the copy of all the web components
polyfills and US v by delta for me and i
have written this into a post install
script so whenever I go into misconduct
will get sexy critic and in my app
gorgeous I will just if I am citing my
web components in this folder directory
structure I can directly import it here
for this
I have created that as a package and I
have installed that package and I'm
importing from that package a demo and
I'm using that directly as a component
inside my F gorgeous and if you will
than this it will be similar as we saw
previously and we can just execute this
and use this command so it's really
simple to use web component in your
legacy project or any existing project
you can plug it in anytime you know any
kind of project and similarly it's
really simple to integrate with view for
angular it's a bit complicated but we
have provided some reference for them
and you can always go through those
links and check that there are some best
practices while you are working on web
components always creative side those
who would whenever you want to
encapsulate all this tiles create two
side doors open real constructor always
place any children the elements create
into this add those hood so that it
should be inside the dome elements
sighted all the hosts displaced Kyle
by default Xin line means it doesn't
take the height and width so it's better
to set it to block or the line local
flags
it's always better to set the display
property for the hidden hidden attribute
on the host it's basically you will
never be able to assign sin and property
to a host element do not overnight or
set of global attributes the default
property which are used in the native
element do not try to override them in
your custom elements always accept
amitabh data as either extra boots or
prop property so whenever you are
passing the data or passing some kind of
bullies numbers of a string tried to
pass them as a property as we saw like
name it never has a world example do not
dispatch event anytime from a host to
downward to a children always passed
them as a property or the attribute
dispatch events from a children's to
your presence so as we saw we sought to
do change all the events which we pass
from our children's I don't forget it's
basically tells us like what you should
always keep in mind when developing any
custom element accessibility of those
elements it should like be accessible
using these all actually we look if it's
taking all the area actually built if it
can define you should always put the
accessibility of your custom elements
performance try to not use much of
debounce
or any other performance legging method
which can impact the performance of your
element script isn't always the answer
if there is sometimes like you can use
the native HTML only don't always go
with the web components custom elements
be responsive try to define your
components in a responsive manner and
always test your components as much as
possible these are the references we
went through to collect all the content
if you want to go through it especially
the last three which are used for to
integrate your web component with the
angular glue ends yet these are really
useful when you are trying to set it
into a project that's it
because the workshop and if you have any
questions you can ask anything